all right we are back and continuing
with our review of visualization
functions for vision 12.1 um okay where
have we got to before we were looking at
complex stream plots we were realizing
that this situation is somewhat
different so so like complex region plot
there's only one color that is involved
there is that correct yeah you can have
multiple regions and look at different
colors sure yeah okay but fine but it's
a flat color correct and um right so by
the way this thing about the Geo based
plot base maps and coming up with some
new default color schemes like the black
and white is color scheme to go behind a
you know to go behind the Geo density
plot seemed that seems somewhat
important to me
make sure density bar is not gonna look
good until we have that make sense
I think you're saying that's the default
right yeah I think themes are easy fine
well I think so I mean those are geo
themes though so I mean we got to take
there all the geo colors and bring them
down to something much more gray well
I'm not even sure that you necessarily
want as much color or as many things
colored no I know I know I agree with
that but I'm saying minimum case we just
take all of the hue you know all of the
you know make just desaturate all those
colors somehow I am that doesn't quite
make sense I mean take all those colors
towards gray and we could just try it
there's a piece of errant processing
just see what that does I think it's
gonna look a lot better on what time
scale do you think we will get themes
for for geo Geographics I don't know
Jeremy do you know what does Hosea
know what the status of that is
something we have Jose at the moment I
should be working on them maybe starting
next week rasterize from tiles are gonna
be hard because they take up a lot of
space so you need some graphics
post-processing maybe yeah I'm thinking
that needs to be a giant I mean there's
two mekinese so first of all designing
themes is one thing but the you know
what we found is that we often need to
design the mechanism I know but in the
case of graphics Roger we just spent two
years updating the geoserver it's now
finally done if it's just a server I
mean the daily updated no no no no the
data has been updated that's the whole
point
hmm and the whole point is that we're
going towards is vector-based graphics
that's what I was gonna say if these to
be you know I know we're going toward
step but I have no insight into the rate
of progress in that project well it's
been slower than one might like I've
been a lot of issues yeah and I think
that's the key discussion point for our
geo meeting tomorrow ok
fine but I'm just saying there may be a
cheap solution that involves pure image
processing of the tiles okay I mean like
like for example I don't know what's the
what's the image processing operation
that will then literally make that gray
uh what's it called
there's gotta be a way to do that it's
bliss I guess so
I mean it's a Linden white or something
that's good but you know there's got to
be some operation that will do that
right yeah there's an image image is
just setting I forget what it is that
has saturation in it okay but I mean
that would be the most minimal thing to
try to see whether it looks decent
because it's just not gonna look very
good if you have you know orange you
know density values just going on top of
green parks and so on
right I mean the other approach that you
get you know will say radar maps as they
go as the plot part goes sort of full
saturation what you mean they mean so
like if you go to like say wonder ground
or something and look at a radar map
mm-hmm for the weather yeah I know I
know and the background goes to more or
less outline no no anyway you guys can
look at this okay
let's keep going here um okay
multi-panel plots there's nothing to
look at with those it's just the list of
things that are going to get cut
multi-column layouts as extensions to
chart layout and I can't remember if
smooth histogram uses chart layout or
plot layout I think plot layout okay all
right this is just extending region
style two more functions is that correct
mean region style is a new thing yeah
okay so this came up you know so for
instance when you do contour plot 3d
then you see there if you don't give a
styling of the boundary of that region
you have no depth cueing you can't you
just can't perceive it okay so let's
just understand this so we've got and
then our point was that similar issues
comes up for vector plots as well when
you have that for our region what what
happened there
commit this is a region this is the
volumetric region is that correct yeah
Brent but your protein contours of that
function over that region over that
volumetric region I'm confused this
region style represents that throughout
that volumetric region it is a it is a
pink it is thoroughly pink all the way
it's not throughout it's just the
boundary exactly okay so if I were to
clip this this sphere I would see inside
the pink yeah correct okay so this is
showing the region that is the ball the
outer the skin this is like the skin
style option of anatomy plus sure sort
of yes and in general if you read the
reference page there it says there's two
styles to is gonna be an interior style
and a boundary style and in the case of
3d there's only a boundary style we have
know a graphic system or you know has no
way of styling the interior anything or
your metrics ok berberine there's a
clipping style in general if we were to
clip the edge of that that region right
bowing I don't don't forget you should
put it in there in the MRC also the skin
ster Anatomy skin style really is
extremely analogous to this okay I'll
make a note for that let look just
bugs even die this one here yeah it's
just some bug um hmm let's just look at
this just for a second to see what this
actually does um
right I mean it's the same type of thing
it's contextualizing the data that
you're seeing um okay so here yeah it's
the same deal so wait a minute so in the
in the case of 2d this region style you
don't have that yet but in the case of
if you go back to the other notebook
there is an example of it in vector
plots there well region so in that case
it's coming from a region function
instead of being plotted over the region
what do you mean where is region style
here
they let us see your cursor those ovals
I don't see a region style oh right I
mean the region style is automatic and
so if you have something that isn't the
full region it kicks in so if I say
region style no it's not gonna work
because prototype build failed and
whatever but that would give you a
yellow disc so that is the styling of
the region if there is a region correct
and there are two styles interior and
boundary alright how are those
characterized inside the region style
thing so you see it's light blue inside
and it's dark blue the boundary how do
you say that in the region style there's
a pair of colors similar to exclusion
style because edge form also work
sure I mean it probably should the
question and I think it will the thing
to be careful of is depending on how
that region gets you know constructed
from yes a an implicit region or
something there may be interior
structure that an edge style would pick
up okay how did we do this previously
how do we determine that color there
previously is that just plot style it's
not quite plot style it's close but how
ours it determined previously if I say
region plots here and I want to make
that yellow or something sorry yes yes
that's plot style okay so explain to me
why that's plot style but why something
else is region style cuz it's the
primary thing for the plot okay so
presumably region style should still
work here and do that with region well
it's not doing any region here I mean if
you plot the region plot over a region
yeah okay let's do that I mean so if we
say this and we say region function
arrow why doesn't that work why doesn't
that work it's already reach anything
okay well I mean arguably this should
work it might didn't what determines the
color of the boundary of the yellow
region their boundary style so why
exactly is it that you want region style
to just be one so otherwise it would be
you know boundary region style and
interior region style will be two
different options
is that desirable is that not desirable
it seems heavy for what it is I'm just
worried about the function something
called Regent style which sounds
extremely generic being something kind
of obscure like this given the list of
all regions its regions that are kind of
secondary regions its regions that were
determined regions that arose because
they were carved out by region function
Roger do you have any comments for us
yeah but but but kind of what you're
proposing is making it even more major
by making it two options - I'm saying no
no I agree with understand but I'm
concerned that if somebody sees region
style they're gonna think it's a much
more important thing than this secondary
use and if we if we are gonna have
region style it better be supported in
region plots again though it may be
synonymous to plot style what other
things have regions and them I mean
every every kind of plot I'm very
confused here I'm sorry I'm very very
confused because if I do a random you
know plot 3d something like this you
know um and then I say region function
arrow this right I'm gonna get that
beautiful okay so now my question is if
I said region style arrow pink hair what
would it do it would pink region style
thing out because it's not a supported
option theoretically you know if it's
supported or when it's supported the
region style right I mean there's sort
of two possibilities here right one is
that it shows a planar disc
actually for the region function there's
only one case it has to show a cylinder
I see the skin is the cookie cutter so
to speak is the actual is the is the
locus of the cookie cutter doing the
cookie cutting so to speak right yeah I
know but it's it's a question of us
thinking through I mean there's another
project of look I like the skin idea
okay I think it's useful to have to show
skin so to speak in these things I think
it's useful here yeah if you did filling
to bottom hair you would get it okay
okay let's look at that I don't think I
would get it out to go yeah I don't
think we have a way to do to do full
skin so you know that's why I'm
advocating that the more common thing
here will be boundary region or region
boundaries style because that would make
it clear what's going on here if we did
region boundary stuff but you're clear
right the region boundary in 2d is just
a curve I understand that okay Austin
the problem is that the regional style
here
we can't live up to because the full
region we're not dealing with we're only
dealing with the skin that's right so
which which is why I'm suggesting that
if we could do it here if we could say
region boundaries style in the three in
the you know in this case now the only
case that we are missing is this case
here where the interior of the region is
is rendered right which we can't get
okay and we we don't care about that for
region plot because that's the main
event and so it's the plot style right
this is a secondary rendering and I
personally advocate calling it region
interior style and that it simply isn't
supported in 3d yet although it may one
day be so
how do we feel about the name region
filling style not terrible I think I
like that I like that actually I mean
what about filling wait a minute what
does filling style we have and so you
know retie understandable what would
filling style do in this case what does
filling style do in a vector plus
nothing okay because there's nothing to
fill okay so my question is if there is
a thing which has a meaningful okay
either the region is the main event or
the region if the region is the main
event then it is is there what does
filling style do for region plots I
don't think anything I mean filling
style only villain style was designed
for a for functions for curves and
surfaces to fight between two things and
that's how the whole thing is described
today okay fair enough okay I think this
should be region filling style I like
that name
and you know what we could do look
here's what we could do region filling
style could take edge forms if it wanted
to so you could switch the two of them
together but the more common thing and
the documented thing for the 3d case
will be region boundaries style is this
unless we want to go anatomical and call
it regions skin style I don't find too
squeamish myself um okay alright I think
this will work
Roger are you okay with this yeah no no
it's the same thing is split on two
options it's and it seems fine okay
because then
what I went often you hear me object
when we give too many missions to the
same symbol because then you can't know
I know documentation is not
object-oriented so to speak it's yeah
right I understand okay let's have a
quick look through any other things here
and then we'll go on to the next topic
how did you get these notes by the way
do I have to send this to you oh good
sounds a screencap it okay okay um okay
so default colors are still to come here
so we'll need to look at those again um
alright and there's nothing and nothing
more in these because these are these
are a little bit funky I mean complex
region plot is showing the flat region
that satisfies a boolean predicate
correct right correct
so those are common shapes there include
sectors disks annulus okay so if I say
complex region plot of like abs of I
mean you know ABS of Z cubed is greater
than one Z goes from minus four might
for I you know I wish I didn't have to
give these specifications like this they
really are a nuisance or a pain to type
I agree I wonder whether we could do
something different so I has an idea if
we say Z comma four
maybe it's the unit it's the bounding
square around the unit around the you
know other words Z comma one would be
the unit circle unit circular units or
the - one - one - one - one that the the
the thing bounding the unit circle so to
speak right I think that will be useful
and I don't see any problem with that I
don't think there is I mean we can
implement that easily enough I think
fine let's do it cuz I get really
annoyed doing these some I have no idea
what any of these look like well that's
not very exciting is it um so if I do
this
why doesn't that work same reason as
region plot doesn't work for curves and
points I see so that will be complex
contour plot so if I say if I do this
and I say complex contour plot that's
not gonna work because it's a less than
one I don't know why the contour plot
doesn't work for that I guess it's a
boolean so that is such ugly colors but
I understand the thing so now if I say
equals equals one good I get the curve
okay all happy so now in the case of
complex vector plots I don't even know
what that's doing okay so that's going
to give vectors and how it really needs
to be yeah I mean it so that's a real
valued thing so they all point to they
all point to the real direction okay
very cool okay now let's talk about
arrowheads for a minute okay they're
pretty heavyweight here
what are you doing with arrow heads as
the if I did a plot if I did an image
size arrow tiny am I just know I'm not
all arrow it's good exercise full those
arrowheads are really too heavy in my
opinion so are they too heavy on are
they too heavier are they too heavy in
relation to the shaft I think primarily
to the shop but I don't know Jeremy do
you have an opinion about if you said
you know vector style goes too thick on
that um
I'm sorry so saying back to style goes
to thick weather I really like that term
that change we're just describing about
the Z comma for being the unit you know
not the unit the right so of the
rectangle you know I wonder whether we
should do that with them now we can't do
that with other things that's not a plot
3d thing is that's that's a feature of
the fact that it's a vector thingy um oh
yes
sander is pointing out that that
tomorrow our live stream is pointing out
the plot range arrow 4 gives - 4 - 4
yeah it's absolutely consistent a plot
range arrow 1 in in graphics in graphics
and graphics 3d plot range arrow 1 it's
consistent with what plot range does ok
so I'm sorry what were you saying - that
looks less ugly it's not great bits less
ugly is it I mean is Jeremy here I'm
here yeah I don't mind this at all
especially you can actually see the
color now so if you go much smaller on
both the color is kind of pointless
fair enough so the issue here was
without this what would be if I say thin
there for example yeah that looks well I
mean it doesn't look terrible I mean you
could decide that the arrowheads are the
main event you see if you do this he
might as well as get rid of the shafts
altogether
yeah I agree but I don't think that's
obviously bad but that's what you get in
your vector what are you calling a
vector markers right so is there
something that is you know all had no
body type thing for the arrows there is
but it is you
it's a very triangle thing I think you
know there's room for one that's a bit
more has a little bit more style to it
yeah by the way Sanders pointing out the
problem is that the line thickness
doesn't scale but the arrowheads do he's
right or is that is he right I mean that
the line thickness scales in a situation
like this what happens to that line
thickness that thickness
I mean thick is an absolute thickness I
see
she's probably wrong so I mean if the
arrowhead is scaling so should the
thickness be scaling right no although I
mean that's what thick is I mean if you
do input form of thick yeah yeah oh yeah
anyway look work needs to be done on
this we got to get these I mean these
arrows need to be more consistent and
need to scale properly fair let's see
what we can do okay I mean that sounds
like a Tim issue I don't know but okay
did we go through everything here I
think so
supporting multiple regions Oh brilliant
go ahead so sorry yeah I forgot we
hadn't looked at region plot 3d is that
I mean is there anything on obvious
there so to speak not really no so I
mean by by multiple regions you just
mean if I say X square plus y Scoob
Z to the 4th less than one and you know
something else here yep you'll get two
volumes and different colors and now
here be lovely if I didn't have to go
missing
in the expect after the - forum okay
cool well now we've got those same
famous colors again they look good
together but Jeremy I'm sorry were you
here for that discussion about the color
flipping yeah I was I don't know what to
do about it I mean these colors look
beautiful together but I agree that it's
crazy that it's color flopping thing it
wasn't it cleared me if people wanted
them to match but be distinguishable or
whether they should be completely
different
I think matching but distinguishable
would be nice hmm and it might give us
an opportunity to redo the color of our
core plots
I think this blue is a bit dull but I
think which flu go want to start with
blue but not that blue I mean if we have
a more vibrant palette but we could use
well I don't know that we want to start
with Lou I'd be happy to start with a
color other than blue like in a reddish
color or something I mean I think that
the I think they're looking a bit drab
these days mm-hmm
I mean I'm not sure you want to start
with a bread but not bright red I
remember you know I think we adapt
because these colors were sort of a big
step up from the legacy default styles
and and now we've adapted and gotten
used to that if we want to step it up
again
I think it's nice it's it's no I'm just
saying it um I don't think that supports
call out yet actually I'm sure it
doesn't what would it what would it do
does it support any of those things
labeled no does it support term legend
did legend did probably not yet those
would be nice to have I mean that's
absolutely we should make work does
call-out work at all in 3d some for some
for some things but like 300 plots
3d I think as
why if it worked for parametric plot why
the hell doesn't it work for for region
plot I mean doesn't seem like it's a
because surface is right now right but
the other thing our battery regions yeah
but the other thing is that for these
functions the wrapper support was not
very complete so new parsers new ways of
handing it needs to be written for each
one I say so if I were to do parametric
plot 3d I don't know what I can just
look at the docks well I mean you're
saying together to get an image okay so
let's say this one here I don't know
what this really looks like but and then
if I say oh I see I need multiple
whatever they only need one I mean you
can do a call-out on okay but if I were
to say call out slash out that doesn't
that work why is that exactly supported
parametric 430 maybe it's only the kerf
kiss or maybe I'm just completely
confused just possible so you're saying
parametric plot let's just see I mean it
would be nice to support more of these
alright so you
okay so that looks like it's
successfully legend ed um so in this
case we could say something like oh it
might need an evaluate is that possible
that is possible or it's possible that
okay so what happens if I don't have the
evaluator you probably do need to
evaluate well so maybe that maybe these
other ones actually did work better
ah well so so in fact we don't actually
know that these didn't work I wish we
had a better heuristic faux fur for
determining whether you need evaluate I
mean at least advising the user when the
things gonna come up with a blank plot
oh that worked beautifully
you know what can we talk about that for
a second sure if it's gonna come out
with a blank plot couldn't it heuristic
we determine um that it needs evaluate
possibly we might even be able to
determine it earlier why don't you look
at it because silly in these cases where
you know in a case where it's like
mapping call out or something we kind of
know we need it let's have a little
effort to try and do that so I mean we
don't even know whether this one didn't
work let's see whether this one worked I
am sure that one didn't work well this
didn't give an error there right um okay
there was a couple of questions on the
live stream one is about support for
around and 3d does that work not yet we
might get a little bit of that in 12.1
but it wasn't ready by today so
gonna work it's gonna make ellipsoids so
we're looking at adding support for
around to list plot 3d in this point
plot 3d and you know probably have you
know sort of the stem approach you have
the lines and orthogonal directions I
say so it looked like one of those jacks
so it looked like the Lutz curves fine
that's bounding curves right so it'll
look like some kind of coordinate axis
Jack type thingy thingy yep got three
does that look decent it's not great
looking I've never seen 3d era buzz like
that I'm pretty sure I have but it's
still a little bit earlier I'm I want to
experiment with using like little tubes
for the lines instead just to give it a
little bit more fine yeah I agree that
that's a sander is suggesting the very
simple heuristic try running the plot if
it's empty then evaluate try rounding
the plot that's a little scary cuz
evaluate could blow up a lot of stuff
but I kind of agree that that's most
likely what one should do and at the
very least it's going to produce that
produce an error message just said you
probably need evaluate it's also the
case by the way that this is something
we could feed to the code assistance
team that some of these cases you can
pretty much predict you're gonna need a
value eight is easy I'm saying and we
could actually do that in there in the
code it's just sort of suggestion thing
right I mean the other thing that just
occurred to me is that you know
potentially the suggestions bar could
also recognize when it got an empty plot
out that is a good idea
look there are multiple places we that
this is a this is a common error people
shouldn't be being bitten by it we
should be able to deal with it but
that's very Swank that that works do you
think that would work with call-out as
well if it worked with labeled it works
with call-out okay
um okay
our then he plans to enable plot layout
and plot it that's not the works
club but not for plot right I mean I
assume they mean the multi-column sort
of thing and the answer is yes we're
just doing data things first okay um
okay
I think we are oh I'm sorry I didn't
look at complex stream plot and I just
wanna have a quick look at that um let's
go back to these complex things so this
so this thing here we should see the
force lines of force so to speak mm and
it Pink's which is a spectra stuff
vector style thick obviously it needs to
know that that's not an option but okay
why is that well that's a bug that's
since been fixed okay yes you know it
would be the stream plot equivalent of
well on what color of the screen is just
blue stream plot just a robot stream
plot okay okay fine all right let's see
we have a question here from you're
gonna kill my session with variables
like D that is a bit disappointing isn't
it that has to do with boy there has to
do with the evaluation stuff again
because the
I saw both look the same and they'll
both look like the first one yeah that's
not great it's a good example actually
can you you should probably capture that
one Bret right Aaron Roger and I were
just discussing discussing that we need
sort of possible issues highlighting the
evaluates no cases yes but also also
that's not good enough I mean we really
need to solve this problem yeah yeah
yeah towed assist suggestions bar you
know messages and hopefully an actual in
you know execution time heuristic all
right do I need to keep this beautiful
notebook I don't think so okay all right
I think we're on to a new topic
we're off the next topic Roger what
what's next so we have this little bit
left you want to do on catalyst and we
have graphs and networks and we can pick
either
I don't want should we do it should we
try and nail calculus and then then do
what we can on graphs and networks after
that sounds good okay all right where am
I going
you sent me the relevant stuff for the
calculus yeah I actually have it saved
in your chat box okay great it's an e
top level of SW notes it's called
calculus and algebra and then a date
okay that's a new cloud feature okay
right hold on calculus and
thank you by the way generally it's not
great to put them in the top level
they're rather than a subdirectory but
if there wasn't a subdirectory so be it
yeah I couldn't find once okay all right
where are we looking at first you wanted
to look a little bit more I think we
were sort of down with the asymptotic
stuff and you wanted to look a little
bit more about Hoyne functions you
didn't have time to look at fine okay so
they were the asymptotic stuff what I
got convinced by is we agreed we're
going to make series work with inactive
integrate yes so on and that otherwise
this looked quite good and we're gonna
make the the notation I mean this
notation we're also gonna make work in
series is that correct right yes I spoke
Danny about it and he's gonna work on it
okay fine um it's very impressive that
the prime stuff and so on being able to
do a lot of customers there is very
impressive just so I understand I mean
the scope of things like it you know the
set of theorems that exist about
asymptotic behavior of discrete
functions do we have a decent do we know
no well it's a long long a story the
first batch of things we do are things
that we could find where people have
recorded okay and we've probably not
found everything because it's sparsely
spread out so we'll make some attempts
on that then how people actually derived
these asymptotic estimates um we
actually have the tools to push that
envelope - that's gonna be a
slower-paced when we have to derive them
ourselves yeah but for instance you know
stuff like Lindelof representations of
them of some of these sequences which
are integral representations and then we
use the asymptotics of that integral etc
okay but so so I mean for things like I
mean if we look at the number theory
functions for example how many of those
do we have asymptotic estimates for well
that's the statistics I didn't get I I
have looked at that they were actually
the notebook is now ready but I would
say that we have to vote maybe 10 to 12
functions and I couldn't find any more
things like you know Mobius me or
whatever so in some cases you might some
limits but no asymptotics but I mean
there are definitely things like sums
with Mobius Muse you know there are
asymptotic estimates of some of those
right uh-huh I mean I know that there
are so uhm I mean if you you know things
like prime Omega that probably has
asymptotic estimates I didn't find
anybody I can check with Charles so
which should probably ask him outside
friendly experts about these yeah as I
said I'm gonna get this I wanted to get
this report now because we had a
strategy which i think is not indecent
and I just want to make sure we execute
that first strategy to find them okay
fine as far as we we can and then you
know then beyond that things will
accumulate more slowly and in some cases
as I said we can push ahead to because
we actually have this Oh like territory
Oh does all I gonna do continuous
function oh yeah he only does continuous
functions these are not really functions
to him sure did you ask him I mean yeah
no he doesn't really okay fine
um okay let's move on this is very
beautiful stuff very nice that's really
cool
some Tata cars solve on like the
Fibonacci thing I will get that's right
yeah you got a leading term basically I
mean however many do you want
yeah so if I do this and I say a of N
equals um yeah my minus 1 plus FN minus
2a if 1 equals equals a of 2 equals
equals 1 that's why I'm trying it
magnificent right now let me try doing
the sub leading terms because that so
that order that's something of a certain
order there so let's try doing four
terms here why no well at that point no
what should we really return because do
we want it
I mean you really have a close form over
here basically you have two things so if
we can find so I mean let me do
something more wild right so see like
wonderful exactly something well no I
think there's not really any more so but
then are these kind of modify Fibonacci
no matter what they're called but you
know to Valachi numbers that sort you
know so if it's not linear what why
can't we do anything with it let me not
get asymptotic estimates in that case so
for a recurrence equations we are it's
severely limited for nonlinear they're
almost nothing you need to strengthen
that on the other hand the linear case
have become very strong in that it can
have very Hank is that that looks
completely magnificent right so that's
what I'm gonna say that it's still
linear oh right so deadly near theory
was developed by Burke often generous in
ski yeah you know following its 1910 and
the final papers like 1935 Jasinski was
in in here by the way in town yes huh
yeah and and out of
perk up students actually it's
incredibly cool that that works I mean
look at that limit that's a good example
by the way can I send you that one
sure please um yeah so deaths that
linear theory you know with meromorphic
coefficients is it's it's completely
sorted out okay you can put something
like cosine of what you know with the
same metamorphic behavior I mean you
have to make sure that they actually
have something that it probably should
work now so uh sine of n PI over three
is that we aren't meromorphic at
infinity so pick something else like you
know sine of Phi with two ends of that
sort something is actually metamorphic
than you okay well that's it okay I mean
that's wiggling a lot of infinity right
but you hey I think you need to have
meromorphic I didn't finicky basically
that that's what the condition do you
need I see okay well anyway but it's
very impressive I'm really impressed I
mean this is really useful and okay so
we should be able to one day we should
be able to take a bunch of our
algorithms now the question is do we
have for example if we take the compiler
okay which has decent analysis of
certain kinds of code are we able to
digest that code into something where we
can do these asymptotic estimates and
that's more a question for Roger I mean
right so this is this is sort of
automated analysis of algorithms yes
which is something I want us to do we
have we have almost all the core
building blocks for it but in terms of
sort of meeting their ground we need to
the right way is something proposed by
should Sandburg or in the sixties which
is basically specifying a grammar for
how these events are generated that you
can map to programming language really
well so from that we can get a giant
generating function from which we can
get the asymptotics or we can get the
recurrence of functional recurrence
equations
which we can also get the asymptotics
you know I just wonder in terms of
generating recurrences I mean like from
a Turing machine for example I wonder
whether there's a cuz I did some
analysis at one point of some Turing
machine there's to give you an example
and I don't know whether this is
automatable show you one thing um
the sky I mean this is an example of
just absurdly there's just some
particular Turing machine
I have no idea what this is automatable
but that's it's running time computation
I think most algorithms that you want to
kind of analyze even if you don't I
think most algorithms are not that
complicated actually um well most the
humans right are not that complicated
but a decreasing fraction are written by
humans right I think that that's there
that's still the very cutting edge of
what we can hope to do at this point I
think in terms of getting far enough
fully automated
but I mean so the question would be
given this algorithm like Euclid's
algorithm or something for G CDs given
this input what is the you know figure
out the it will recurrence equation for
the running time yeah since for today
you would teach that in a basic data
structures and algorithms class would
teach how you do accounting basically
for that algorithm to setup recurrence
for it and if you give if you give us
the recurrence we can solve it if you
give us now the generating function we
can solve it I understand that but so
the question is given the algorithm
itself you're saying if you tag it as
every multiply costs this amount or
whatever else right so then then there
is there is another step to get even
closer to that as I said which is did
you want to be able to tag kind of
algorithms and and automate that like
okay let's let's go looking at wind
functions I think Olek has been
promoting Hoyne functions for the last
several years hasn't he yes sure because
that is the next kind of target of the
hypergeometric so I am no idea what they
are right so they are kind of
generational hypergeometric they've got
four regular singular points 0 1
infinity an arbitrary you know as the
years go by we're gonna have more and
more regular singular points right is
that I use serious it's not the number
of arguments of this function yes
because of the differential equation
itself is massive I mean it's it's not
easy to work with if you look at the
differential equation messy somewhere
over there and then you'll see that if I
could require the arguments to get
anywhere so are we sure we don't want to
put those arguments in a list we could
do that right Roger
well motion are we gonna have to use
this special functions people hate lists
this nothing works for them which
special our special functions people our
special functions people and it's mostly
because of derivative and a few other
things don't work properly but so do all
these Hawaiians have have this many
no there's a general horn function which
is like another hypo Jubilee to f1 a pfq
then little conference which you
filled that hammock what's not cfq it's
a it's a limited number of parameters
here right right yeah but you said he
does use lists yes me too a find of - if
I'm sorry - f1 it's more like - f1 I
would say - f1 is a better analogy in
fact - what is it is a special case of
hoin okay so if I want to go wild here I
could do something like this and I could
say is this crazy if I could say complex
plot so this is just check it's gonna be
a race I don't know all the look but you
can try it for sure it might be
complication very slowly
yeah how what how are we doing the
numerical approximation of these
creatures right so in continuation they
literally do in continuation order
differential equation and why are we not
trying to use like machine learning to
try and get estimates of what of the
values we just run it for lots of cases
and we try and generate a neuron that
that basically approximates the function
yeah I mean it's a high dimensional
function so obviously we'll I mean first
of all I mean we do this in order to
guarantee it okay
I don't think machine learning could
guarantee a thing to be honest I don't
know depends on what we know about how
smooth the function is yeah I don't
think that there is any work that shows
that it can guarantee digits of
precision yeah I think that if you stay
inside in that the unit circle maybe it
might be quicker because there's not
that much continuation to do over there
so what is it doing here it's doing
you're saying it's actually doing
analytic continuation in in the wild
live yeah because I mean that it's if it
can it reduce to hypergeometric and I
think there are 18 own special cases
over there where - this is hyper
geometric but those are few and far
apart compared to the general hind
function it's just a plot really works
but it takes some time okay so let's go
unit circle here
that's not quite the unit circle you
want me to be actually within the inside
and see I mean you want a radius which
is inside all right
but I'm not sure they're even that it
will be slow plot really barely and may
take some time but it will work well
with this thing returns complex values
doesn't it yes of course yes sure I'm
saying that in terms of you know
competition the best I've tried is plot
3d okay well we'll let that thing run
for a moment okay yeah so other than the
fact that these have a you know a giant
festival of arguments yeah um if there
are any branch courtesies that I'm sure
we've done as well as we can with the
branch cuts for these right so the they
were forcing in the points one is a
reckoning one is zero one infinite the
fourth one is arbitrary and so that you
can pick at will and then your branch
cut gets the determined by that fourth
point basically because everything else
is kind of fixed based on hypergeometric
to f1 and do we have to basically think
about oh look at that
not bad Frank that's really strong why
is it all red Roger any idea i mean well
but the indicates phase phase is
constant which seems on the suggests
that or surreal it's a real number
that's impossible
try I mean it does seem very implausible
that suggests that the if I pick a
random value here 0.7 plus I or
something well okay that wasn't inside
the unit circle let's say 0.2 I know I
don't believe this something went wrong
I mean we can this will just give phase
right yeah I mean it's beautiful but but
it just seems wrong I agree that doesn't
seem right at all okay okay I don't
think it's possible for it
yeah well I mean maybe that maybe
there's this but that suggests some
problem with the heuristic what what
it's the same color I'm kidding but what
the heck this looks like no it is the
same color
it is God it's actually pink yes it's
actually pink it's positively pink like
the Panther I suppose it's not a pink
era
it's a pink function okay but there's a
money issue yeah it's very fishy I mean
if I change that to like two or
something let's see what it does you
know that is a classic if I might say so
I'm gonna save this file because that's
just such a bizarre and classic thing um
I I've never seen a thing that looks
like a pink box actually generated by a
function yeah um did you move the where
this wasn't in the design folder I think
I was Devin who is doing that right now
I didn't I didn't touch anything else
okay okay this is wrong something is
very wrong here okay I mean it's
probably a math problem all right
nothing else we need to look at here
looks like we're done with the calculus
stuff yes I think so
nice okay and and what can we what is
the point function hooked up to I mean
what integrals and things can dissolve
so it's primary primary purpose in life
is to you know it's defined by
differential equation and it's able to
handle these additional singularities
right there to f1 and so Tigran the
it's just finished it's double PhD
exactly his dad worked on horn functions
- can you believe that
anyways there's a lot of quantum
everything you saying a two-generation
Hoyne function yes through generation
horan finished specialists and in his
ph.d he gave a lot of quantum physics
epic a quantum computing kind of give me
take a look yeah so quantum physics and
also black holes so there are in the
upper yeah I've heard when functions are
used in modern ATSC of T stuff yeah so
they're quickly picking up and I think
it's good that we have them right now so
that it seems like people do okay well
don't forget to promote them don't
forget to tell them tell a black hole
people we have them yeah we thought
write a blog post at some point about me
Tigran will fine yeah great okay let's
move on to the next thing things that
work alright what's next
graphs and networks right right Devon do
you have that file somewhere place for
me no I was only included for the
calculus discussion not a problem okay
where is that file Roger did you did you
I'm gonna send a new one but it wasn't
it in the calendar before but
okay and so remind me what we would we
were looking at sanitation's Jana said a
Lincoln chance okay and we have geometry
to said but I did you know we have only
15 minutes left sits thank know what
were we doing in geometry again
well there was there there was the
topology and metric searches so oh yeah
yeah yeah I really would gain you didn't
send us in check oh maybe we did hold on
um I'm not there now Drock a chat but
the zoom chest okay
okay I didn't get it could you resend
please um oh wait a minute it says sent
to okay now I see why so that's the
geometry one sort of let me get their
graph in network one it was somehow it
pointed my chat to Charles only there
you go okay so it's a wait a minute
geometry we had not finished the
discussion about how to do all these
various shading things there was a great
functionality but we're not really
finished with figuring out precise
details of how everything will work
we're closed right we didn't look at
this at all
we don't you exactly and we looked very
briefly on geometry in geography and I
don't think that there is much to say I
actually think we the geometry in
geography I was pretty happy with I mean
that I understood what that was that's
being able to do things here I mean I
assume oh I see Gio area so if I just do
a straight geo area of the United States
okay hold on let me just try this I'm
trying to understand this so if I say
okay I'm going to look
couple of different things here if I say
geo area of us then it's just gonna go
to the area property isn't it it's not
gree computing that is it uh I think
it's just the area property for I'm
pretty sure it is it's not it's not okay
so we got this two here and I I think
the issue is gonna be even more extreme
if we do this so I reckon we probably
don't know that air so that that area is
sort of entities stored area exactly
but if I say geo area of Sydney now if
we have the boundary of certainly which
we male Minot's okay fine
not available but but that's an issue I
don't know what the I mean again the geo
area does what if what does it do with
lakes
what does geo area I mean what's what's
comparable for us is is geo area you
know in terms of geometry
cuz that's computing something and then
there's a question of what's that why
are there differing the entity stored
value and a computer I understand that
but I want to know what Lakes
what happened to the Great Lakes do you
see what I'm saying just geo area
include the Great Lakes or not include
the Great Lakes I see as I
can imagine that one of these is the
political area so to speak the
controlled area and the other is the
polygonal area well geometry just looks
at geometry whatever polygons well so
it's not gonna know like you know the
territorial waters of whatever it's not
gonna know right unless unless I mean
the polygons can can include holes in
them absolutely but I don't think I
think that okay the polygons look what
you're seeing here is that the Geo area
is smaller suggestion to me that the
Great Lakes have been chopped out of the
United States polygon but they're not
chopped out of the United States
political area so to speak saying yeah
yeah I get it
it could also be that I wonder what that
polygon if that's sort of the lower 48
only I think Alaska is bigger than that
but I'm not sure um but okay so look
there's an issue here so I don't know I
don't know if Jose is here probably not
we didn't think we were doing this
particular thing right right um okay you
were right no Alaska where as I bet this
includes Alaska right okay and we've got
a geo variant here you know this thing
here allows to your variant it's it's
gonna get complicated right so I think
this just becomes a you know a possible
issue to say the area isn't necessarily
the same as the declared you know
political area so to speak make sense
right I don't think this is a problem
now I
the same ambiguity that's been dealt
with for years there right and so in the
case of region centroid what we'd be
doing there in that I see so in that
case we'd be saying okay so let me just
understand if we do region centroid of
well United States for example what why
not
it doesn't work on the entity it's build
on job position polygons so you need to
go not but that what did work on there
oh it's a region centroid so it's not a
Geo region centroid so you're saying if
I say polygon of that you know why
didn't that work so you have to actually
get the property which gives you the job
position that's not that's not sensible
look come on I mean this is why can't I
take this region see what I'm saying I
mean
the question is that because if you view
it as a polygon on a on a right but this
one the ellipsoid the centroid will be
inside of the earth exactly for sure but
this worked right so Geographics a
polygon of us worked so I don't see a
reason why region centroid shouldn't I
mean if I say okay so let's say I say
geo area of polygon of United States
you
um and I have that sorry yeah that works
geo area of that worked sure but an area
does area work on that no I see I see I
see so what do I have to do here so in
this case you actually need to like you
know if you want to actually compete you
have to precise the projection so you
need to actually United state of
coordinate on job position out of it so
if I were to say okay so if I would say
geo position here that's really
confusing considering that okay so wait
a minute if I say this are you saying
that that will finally work put it on a
fun point no it won't because this isn't
a polygon at one point what's your
position polygon of job position two job
position will return one point it won't
look at this case here no in that case
we had to coordinate and then we applied
the Mercator projections compared to
your comment which is well I'm can
by this I think we need to look at this
a little bit more um let's let's try to
understand for one second what what
you're saying if I were to say geo
position geo grid position here Randall
so essentially you have to describe give
a specific position to tell us
essentially you are given the position
on the map of that polygon but still
just one pointer yeah it doesn't make
sense but how do you get I don't know
how you get it up from entities we know
that's not gonna give it because
coordinates would give okay this is very
confusing I think the question is how
you get it from entities we know I could
get it now coordinates there he stopped
the thing
that entities data but that's not entity
I don't know
so we need okay this is messed up okay
we need a we need some thing here and
then the question what this should do I
mean the ideas sample I mean this issue
is for is on the anti decide how to
position or coordinate I understand I
understand so we don't have the right
people here to answer this right okay in
the time that remains why don't we take
a look at um these things here okay mesh
connectivity graph adjacent mesh cells
okay which should I look at here any of
them but go to the ref page
cuz it's squared the information is now
let me explain a simple case for a mesh
connectivity graph so you know let me
bring up a meta Menger sponge or
something sure okay
okay so the simple case is where you
kind of almost see where the graph is
which relates to you know vertex vertex
connectivity
cool okay and that's what it does by
default that's just a default setting
okay but there are many other kinds of
connectivity because the way a cell
complex is built it has points yeah just
faces in general K faces okay and and
you know so all of these can be related
so the question is like what are the
edges that are neighboring my points I
see so this this is looking at two two
complexes or whatever - and this one
looks at you know where did the
rectangles near each other and the edge
represent near-term saying next to each
other
my rectangle you mean the the little
regions inside the little regions inside
are no nodes in this graph and edge says
the two of those rectangles and NASA
that should presumably generate a
message yeah it's a - too big of a
dimension yeah obviously I know but I
just I'm just suggesting Internet's a
message absolutely okay so those are the
edges right okay so can I take a sample
like dinosaur or something yeah um how
do I get a sample dinosaur yeah well
whatever region search is probably the
easiest or you can take
cow from example data or something like
that let's take the example cow what is
it called geometry 3d yeah why didn't
that work I should just probably give
you better names okay let's take the cow
okay there it is Moo oh yeah yeah it
gets it that's a mesh because it's this
operates on meshes otherwise you need to
convert it to imagine stuff like that
what is this is this graphics 3d here
yeah so get it out get it out from
example data just as a mesh region
directly now you have the right thing
okay okay okay so now I can say mesh
connectivity graph
of that guy and then the default is
points so it's gonna be a cow like graph
right okay but that graph isn't is not a
3d object that's just a graph that's
just a graph here well excuse me why is
that rotating in 3d because we have
graph 3d right you can pick the three so
it's it's choosing I see so it knows
it's the 3d object so it's embedding the
graph in 3d
apparently that works fairly well for 3d
objects
yeah it's obviously a good idea for 3d
objects okay so if we go here and we do
the cow and we do like like regions of
the cow yeah so that will be a similar
but almost dual to this picture so
correct yep what the hell is that that
is that what the hell is that
that's a dual cow that's really wild
telesco dos patches are neighboring each
other on that cow topologically well
that's my favorite picture from the day
like how it reminds me of you know
modern string theory you know
holographic principles and things of I
don't know what okay so when we explain
this to me so that the hooves of the cow
I mean we can do a super simple example
where we can reason our way through it
okay but this is a great function okay
so what else do I need to know about
this function that's it it gives you
know so if you're in 3d you know this is
referred to on the guide pages from
graphs cuz there's a useful way to
generate obviously yes it's not done
right now but we have all that knitting
to do one thing here is that if you're
in dimension D and you have a cell
complex there immediately D plus 1
squared such for possible graphs or
relations okay
okay and usually a geometric data
structure is optimized for one or two of
those relations they make them very fast
okay so but anyways here you can get
them all and they are actually fast too
to work within this graph but the other
ones the other one that's their adjacent
mesh cells is the nearest goes based on
this ignore that illustrate so in it so
I should look for adjacent master cells
like jason mesh cells is very close to
what we just looked at what that does it
allows you to to walk that mesh I mean
the graph allows you to walk the mesh in
however way you want to but there Jason
mer cells so you have the mesh region
tell you know I'm at this cell and I can
tell you whether it's a sort of an area
cell or a line cell or a point cell and
so if I go to the manager creature yeah
oh I I would say adjacent mesh cells of
that comma and then let's say cell four
or something
is there a cell 4 you'd usually do
there's a short form to give it is to
sort of say dimension comma index so
list dimension kamay index so let's say
like a point zero comma I don't know 5
or something okay and then what is it
you want someone needs to say what you
want next to it dimension like the
nearest one certain edge okay so for
example why can I not do this in a graph
could I do this on a graph if I say if I
pick if that is the specifier for a node
and if you built the correct relation
that the that has the relation between
points and edges if you have that graph
you can absolutely do all that and it's
in fact optimized for doing lots of that
ok but let me just try to understand
this
so the specifier of a cell here have we
used that kind of cell specifier before
on yes yes where
all the mesh regions boundary mesh
regions and so they have dimension
followed by indexes that correct correct
okay
you can notes you can also do another
thing which is you can have sort of
point of index as it's using in graphics
complex
that's a pointer index that so then if I
go here for example let's say I say
something like this if I say adjacent
cells hash comma whatever it is hash
oops
no I it's in this object I'm gonna go
those cells comma one and then I say
that starting with zero five and then I
go three steps or something I don't
really know how that means that was
almost come a three oh wait a minute
what did you do well I I'm walking out
in the graph so each one of those now
becomes a source right so if I were to
do that for 1 1 okay so edges out yes
right okay if I do that for a serpent's
key mash those indexes may or may not be
to the spatially well interesting cool
do that for a denser sierpinski mash hmm
okay well it's hard to tell exactly
what's going on here but it looks
plausible at least come okay so two
deaths
that's the topology over over mesh that
you can now follow what we you know it
within whatever dimension
yeah yeah what you're walking you're
doing spreading across the mesh yeah I
looking for adjacent cells
exactly but you don't have a way you
don't have any particular way to know
what direction on the mesh you're going
because that isn't necessarily it find
no no no yeah you don't you have no clue
you know you need to look at UM at the
embeddings this is just that this is the
part of over mesh that that's kind of
irrelevant to embedding you can even
have an abstract mesh okay nearest mesh
cells is that going to just tell me if I
do the same thing for nearest mesh cells
here now nearest is just using the
distance you know what is nearest so
that's using the metric
as opposed to what this one used
topology the other one used apology oh I
see so in other words if this was across
a void it will still get there whereas
this is using connect to it connected
this is saying it's connected and that
one is saying across the void it's the
closest yes okay um okay practical point
do we have any more time or do we have
to wrap right now I could go on for a
little bit I gotta go unfortunately okay
um what what can we just look at what
we're missing
I mean wait so we haven't done we still
need to come back to this who's making a
note of what we need to come back to
I can make note of it okay all right and
then then the thing we haven't done is
web reader and search is probably you
wanted did you guys finish that off when
you continued shader no we have not
finished shaders and we also haven't
finished um we really haven't finished
this we really really haven't finished
this no mess connectivity graph we
looked at we didn't look at wing to edge
graph they're not available now but
they're similar in nature okay I can
okay um
you
maybe that was just documentation
changes in number theory although I had
some objections to some of those right
that the and the annotation rules we
looked at that we finish that we felt
that we'd finished the tagging stuff we
convinced ourselves that edge tagged
graph made sense right and yes we're I
think we came to conclusion on that yes
okay well we're pretty close here I
think we played a little bit more stuff
to look at but we're pretty close and I
don't know what other we didn't look at
max fine maximum cut or any of that
stuff that's right but what happened to
vertex labeling we went through and was
an interim project and we've optimized
the label placement for all of the
layouts okay by the way Charles I would
really like okay little little gift okay
could you give us an option for Spring
embedding to to give initial points for
the spring embedding we're trying to
generate something where there's a
sequence of graphs and they are related
to each other but they are going to need
to move the points around slightly you
know some what I'm saying I mean you
must have initial data for the for the
spring electrical embedding correct it
would be really really really nice
otherwise we're gonna end up having to
write our own um okay so this so for
example if I say here what's a good
graph if I just say random graph oops
not working you need to give a list of
age so that's not optimal why didn't the
five go on the outside this this is
being electrical no I understand that I
understand but I'm asking the question
since you just told me you optimized
these things why do they know it's
optimized all the fixed layouts so we
have a huge collection a complete graph
has a fixed layout it's not spring
electrical I should you're saying so you
say you've done the artistry of doing it
for the fixed layouts but you have not
yet done it for the arbitrary layouts
there's some tweaking but it needs
there's there's another round that needs
and it's kind of heavy optimization and
how does that relate to the labeling for
NGO graphics and things which is this
another labeling problem okay what
happens if I go to 3d here why isn't
this rotating should be I know it isn't
it's just refusing to
today that's quite Swank yeah there was
that working before yeah it's really
nice
all right let's I guess um um so dongs
on our live stream is saying it's been
working for the heavily labeled graph
take a connectivity data from a flow
sheet simulator and trying to make views
of that network and it's frustrating
don't know I mean II would love to get
some more that I think we had a lot of
interesting things coming underst the
send the example in yeah please I gotta
run I'm really in trouble now okay all
right see you okay um all right we
should probably wrap up here unless this
yeah this is something else we think we
can cover without Roger
nope okay
stuff alright see you guys soon thank
you all thank you folks on the
livestream probably next livestream
since I'm traveling the next two days
will be on Monday talk to you soon bye